We now have a button in our app.
Although, we want this button to be in the form of, an image of a microphone.
Let's add that image next.
So I'll go back to x code and manage some real estate.
I'll hide the document outline, and slide in the navigator.
And hide the utility area.
There, now if you look in the navigator.
There is this thing called, images.xc assets.
XC stands for x code.
And assets means, that this thing is going to help us manage, assets or
images in our app.
The first thing to notice here, is something called App Icon.
This, is the icon that represents our app on the user's phone.
If you look at the bottom of your screen,
you'll notice that we can add any new images or assets here.
I'll click on the plus button, and then on, new image set.
Let me rename this image set to, microphone.
There, okay.
So, here is an image of the microphone on my computer.
I want to highlight that the size of this image is 100x100 pixels.
By the way, this image is also available in the instructor notes for you to use.
Now, you can feel free to use this image or you can customize your app,
by using your own image or the image of a friend if you like.
All right, I'm going to drag this image in to the one x box.
There it is.
Now, I'm going to start with one x, and
then I'm going to ask you to guess, what two x and three x mean.
So, stay sharp and see if you can figure it out from this example.
All right, so next, I'll go to my story board.
And here I'll make sure that the record button is selected.
And then, I will open up the utility area.
And under the attributes in,
inspector, I will remove the default text that I had added.
And then, I will go under images and
try to find the microphone image that I just added.
Boom.
There is my image.
Now one really curious thing to notice here, is that after I've selected my
button, if I go to the size inspector, this link right here, I can check out and
see the width and the height of my button, which is both hundred.
So that means, that my button has conformed.
To the size of the image.
Okay, I'm going to go ahead and run my project, and there it is.
We've added an image to our button.
Now, one thing to notice here with this image,
is that it looks a little bit blurrier around the edges.
You may have to lean in to see this.
Or I can actually go to the window menu and
change the scale of the phone to 100%.
There, see that the image looks somewhat blurry around the edges?
Hm.
Why do you think the image is so blurry?
Care to venture a guess here?